welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my Mandalorian season 2 and
season 3 video Disney just made a couple
really big announcements about the
future of the Mandalorian and a lot of
other big Star Wars plans for Disney
Plus so we'll break it all down if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we got a
bunch of Clone Wars season 7 episodes
coming up real soon I'll remind everyone
about that at the end of the video - so
you're just breaking this all down top-5
style starting with number 5 last week
there was a big Disney earnings call
they had them on a regular basis for
investors here's all the stuff we're
doing here's how much money we earned
for you during those they always hype up
all the new programming movies TV shows
that are coming soon and any big plans
that they have that they think will be
very successful because they're talking
to their investors so they want to make
them money during that call Bob Iger
Disney CEO talked a lot about their
plans for the future of the mandalorian
series the biggest thing being that
they've changed the mandalorian season 2
episode release date to make it way
sooner than we expected I'll explain why
in a second but great news less waiting
for us before we get more mando episodes
number 4 he also said that Disney has
big plans for the mandalorian and baby
Yoda after the mandalorian season -
which is their subtle way of saying
publicly that they've already renewed it
for season 3 it's great news but not a
huge surprise everyone saw how the mando
and baby Yoda were the most popular fan
favorite Star Wars things in a long long
time
even though the hardcore fans who have
hated Star Wars since Disney bought it
loved the Mandalorian Bob Iger even
hyped up its popularity during the
earnings call because the Mandalorian
series by itself was responsible for
getting millions of extra people to
subscribe and pay for Disney Plus which
is their main goal they want people to
subscribe and pay for their new
streaming service so of course they're
gonna keep making more seasons of it but
because of how much it costs to make
it's about 12 million dollars average
per episode of the Mandalorian I'm only
expecting them to do about five seasons
total I mean I would love more I would
love 10 seasons of the Mandalorian but
within that part of the announcement
they also revealed plans on more Star
Wars Disney Plus series
so number three they're developing a
number of direct spin-off shows from the
mandalorian what that means when I say
direct spinoff is that it be based on a
character that debuted during the
mandalorian series or a big event that
they reference on the series but don't
spend a lot of time showing in episodes
so well this is my top five picks for
what those other spin-off shows will be
in a second but it's a totally normal
Hollywood thing to do when you have a
super popular TV show or a movie not
only do you make a lot of sequels in the
case of movies and more seasons in the
case of that TV show you also develop a
bunch of spin-offs focusing on different
cool characters best example the last
couple of years has been the DC TV
arrowverse they started with arrow then
did the flash and as of next year there
will be a total of nine different TV
shows and spin-offs set in that universe
number two really awesome news the
release date schedule for all the
mandalorian episodes in the Marvel
Avengers Disney Plus episodes will go
like this starting at the end of August
fockin and Winter Soldier will begin the
Marvel people are only doing 6 episodes
per series because they're spending even
more money per episode the length of
those episodes will probably be a little
bit longer than the shorter mandalorian
episodes they're spending about a
hundred and fifty million dollars
average for each of the separate series
that's about the budget of one of their
normal big Marvel movies Falcon and
Winter Soldier will air all six episodes
over six weeks then the week after that
finale the mandalorian season 2 episode
1 will start in October mando season 2
will be 8 episodes just like season 1
then at the beginning of December after
Mandalorian season 2 is over
Marvel's wand division Avengers series
will start and run for 6 episodes they
didn't announce what their plans are in
the early part of 2021 but they have the
Loki series coming there's the obi-wan
Star Wars series that's still being made
they're not gonna start shooting that
till early next year I'll address that
at the end of the video too because
there was a bunch of news about Star
Wars ob1 last week Marvel and Disney
haven't really said what their plan for
December is because there's six episodes
of one division but there's only four
weeks in December so they haven't said
whether or not they're gonna double up
on episodes to get them all out before
the end of December or if one division
is just gonna spill into January because
if they only do one episode per week the
finale wouldn't air till January 9th
which I'm totally fine with but
hopefully they'll announce those details
later so all this means that Falcon and
Winter Soldier will probably start
sometime around August 28th remember all
these TV shows air new episodes on
Fridays so the premiere days will always
be on Fridays
mandalorian season two will probably
start around October 9th and then the
wan division series will probably start
around December 4th we'll probably get
more Falcon and Winter Soldier trailers
and Hwan division trailers this spring
around the Black Widow movie premiere
and because Mandalorian season 2 is
coming before Wong Division will also
probably get the mandalorian season 2
trailer footage sometime around then two
Star Wars Celebration is happening at
the end of August also probably drop
another big trailer for Mandalorian
season 2 around then they didn't really
include any Mandalorian season 2 footage
in the Disney Plus Superbowl trailer a
little while ago but I think that's
mostly because it was meant to be a
Marvel Super Bowl trailer just specific
to their Disney Plus content in number 1
WTF here's my top 5 picks for what those
Mandalorians spin-off shows might be so
I'll just go down this list from 1 to 5
number 1 a direct baby oda spin-off
deepening the mythology of Yoda's race
the new Star Wars trilogy that's coming
supposedly in the next couple of years
is set during the High Republic era
around 400 years ago when Yoda was in
his prime so clearly it seems like Star
Wars really wants to lean on Yoda and
Yoda related things in the next 10 years
which is a very safe bet on their part
financially easy slam-dunk number to a
young Mandalorian Series with a teenage
version of the Mandalorian character
when he was still training on Mandalore
with the Death Watch commandos that
saved him during the Clone Wars they
spent a lot of time during Mandalorian
season one explaining major events in
his history but we've only seen a few
short flashbacks of him being rescued
and you could also use that series to
feature live-action versions of all the
Death Watch Mandalorians that you saw
during the Clone Wars animated series
just make it a show about their group
and their adventures number three a
spin-off with a slightly younger
Mandalorian when he was still working
with the black marketeers from season 1
episode 6 his former coworker named ran
in the Twi'leks Xion also told a lot of
stories about their adventures they had
a long time ago you could do a series
just set during that period with some of
those smuggler characters number 4 next
big one you could do another series set
in present-day near present-day with the
remnants of the Empire speaking of Gus
fring Giancarlo Esposito remember how
they did better call Saul right after
Breaking Bad same basic concept you just
spend the series following around
Giancarlo Esposito smoth Cady and
character most of the time and through
his series you get more flashback
stories to the fall of Mandalore his
dealings with the other leaders of the
Empire at that time him at the height of
the Empire in number 5 last idea just do
a series with Jon Favreau's Mandalorian
heavy infantryman character either a
flashback or you could say he survived
the Empire's attack on the secret
hideout during the Mandalorian episode 8
I'd say - a series based on the armorer
character but I think we're gonna get
more of her story in history in future
seasons the Mandalorian but besides baby
Yoda and Pedro Pascal's mando character
the heavy infantrymen in the armor with
a to other coolest characters on the
series so please just give us more of
them they didn't say when they would
actually start shooting these other
spin-off shows I'm assuming it probably
a couple more years before I see them
but let me know in the comments which
spin-off shows do you want them to make
from the Mandalorian I'll keep doing
more Mandalorian season 2 bonus videos
soon the Clone Wars season 7 episodes
will start in a couple weeks I will be
doing Easter eggs for those every week
so be sure to find a way to watch that
series if you don't have Disney Plus now
however you watched the Mandalorian
episodes that'll probably your best bet
for getting new Clone Wars episodes just
to explain what's going on with Star
Wars obi-wan there's a lot of
conflicting reports because of the drama
a couple weeks ago
so you and McGregor came out and tried
to clarify a lot of that he said that
what they're doing is that they're
spending more time working on the
scripts so they pushed the shoot
schedule to start early next year and
even though that seems like a delay
there's no plans to delay the intended
premiere date that they had originally
had which will probably be later in 2021
there were also some rumors that they
were cutting the episode count from six
episodes to four episodes you and
McGregor said that he didn't know
anything about that he also just went on
the late-night circuit to hype up the
Star Wars obi-wan series wall-e was
talking about birds of prey you are
doing a series right yes we're gonna do
another one we're gonna do another one
we are we have been talking about it for
a long time it's gonna be a movie and
then I decided that it would be a good
idea to do it as a series so we're gonna
make it as a series for a Disney's you
streaming plouf Disney Plus yeah and
[Applause]
prepping I've been watching I liked it I
watched Mandalorian I'm just trying to
keep abreast of all the new Star Wars
films that come out and I'm excited
about it it's been it's been a long time
I remember when the last one I did 2003
it's nice to hear that he's a fan of the
Mandalorian series it just seems like
it's really popular with everybody
that's in and around Star Wars so I'm
just happy that they're gonna be giving
us a lot more Mandalorian so if you
weren't sure what the future of that TV
show is going to be don't worry there
will be a lot of more Mandalorian coming
in future years
everyone click here for all my
Mandalorian season 2 teaser videos in my
Clone Wars season 7 trailer and click
here for my new spider-man venom to
cross over scene video thank you so much
for watching everyone stay awesome this
is the way
[Music]